definitely be emotional Norman Reedus
revealing Walking Dead Season seven
secrets I have to say I was just reading
about Walking Dead Season seven you
called it mind-blowing it's mind-blowing
I mean um you know the thing about that
shows it's it's so personal to us and
it's it's almost weird to talk about I
will say it's well worth the wait
yeah oh yeah fans will be happy fans
will be emotional
I don't know that Happy's the right word
definitely be emotional yeah yeah things
though things will be broken in their
homes it's pretty well yeah but before
Norman goes back to fighting zombies
he's gearing up for his other show on
AMC
ride it's um it's a like a travel
docu-series through the United States on
motorcycles I take a buddy we go on a
ride he teaches me things we meet people
we learn new things we try crazy things
it's a lot of fun between the two shows
when do you find time to sleep I'm
sleeping right now do I look like I
sleep ever I never see I caught up with
the actor at Saturday's Spike TV guys
Choice Awards in LA what is the manliest
thing about Norman Reedus I'm learning
how to make a perfect poached egg right
now quite determined kind of cheating
cuz I have one of those pans a little
circle cups in it but that will
eventually turn into eggs benedict and
then I will reach full manhood
well like chefs at it oh yeah oh yeah
watch out hollandaise sauce will come
the whole thing